[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la guerre des âges ou le dénis
du vieillissement la société française
comme la plupart des sociétés
européennes chacune avec ses
spécificités est constitué d'un archipel
de communauté un archipel de situation
familiale religieuse et territoriale de
mode de vie distinct de valeurs qui
s'entremêlent et parfois
s'entrechoque ce qui fait le sel et le
poivre d'un vivre ensemble qui doit
s'adapter aux transformations et aux
mutations climatiques technologiques et
socioc-culturel avec le risque inhérent
à la société de consommation où tout
passe dans le commerce selon Marx ou le
rêve disparu selon Freud avec aussi le
dénis démographique d'une société qui
tend infailliblement vers le
vieillissement avec certes des limites
biologiques mais que l'espérance de vie
prolonge toutefois avec les aléas du
grand âge sommes-nous préparer à cette
transition démographique qui bouleverse
tous les compartiments socio-économiques
culturels et sanitair lié au
vieillissement de nombreux projets de
loi mais pas de véritaable loi sur le
grand âge parce que ça coûterait trop
cher ou plus cyniquement parce que le
sujet par trop consensuel ne clivrait
pas politiquement c'est ce que nous
allons observer et discuter avec mes
invités mais il est une autre priorité
que nous examinerons aussi et qui a tras
au bouleversement anthropologique d'une
société moderne qui oublie ses vieux en
se privant du monde d'avant des simples
choses de la vie si cher à Georges
Perrec de la part intime de notre
identité passée et de tous ces petits
détails rendus insignifiant par
l'hypermodernité et qui nous permettent
de donner de la vie à la vie pour en
parler je vous présente mes invités
Jérôme Gedge vous êtes député de lesson
conseiller régional
d'Île-de-France Juliette Méadel vous
êtes ancienne ministre vous êtes élu à
Montrouge et président de l'avenir
n'attend pas Hervé Lebras vous êtes
démographe et esséiste Jean-Pierre
Michel vous êtes professeur des
universités notamment en Suisse et
membre de l'Académie nation de
[Musique]
médecine dans votre rapport Jérôme Gede
vous distinguez trois catégories parmi
les personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans
ceux qui sont autonomes en somme en
bonne santé ceux qui sont fragiles et
qui nécessitent un accompagnement et les
personnes âgées dépendantes au total
plus de 20 % et si on en croit les
statistiques 30 % en
2050 avec les besoins quantitatifs
qualitatif aussi massif nécessaire par
les situations rencontrées comment faire
en attendant cette loi du grand âge qui
est programmé pour
2024 d'abord il faut regarder le sujet
le problème qu'on a la démographie je
parle sous le couvert d'Hervé lebrass
est tonitruante dans les informations
qu'elle nous fournit et s'il y a bien un
phénomène totalement prévisible c'est
celui du vieillissement de la population
et c'est vrai que nous sommes entrés
dans une période de massification je
vais même dire de triple massification
du vieillissement les trois catégories
que vous avez mentionné je les ai pas
inventé je les ai emprunté au gériâre
c'est une une pyramide qui est celle de
la robustesse les fragilités et la perte
d'autonomie encore que çaett on peut y
mettre des born d'âge qui ne veulent pas
dire grand grand-chose parce que on peut
être en situation de fragilité à 62 ou
63 ans parce que on a une pathologie
parce qu'on a eu une carrière avec des
métiers pénibles et cetera mais pour
schématiser mettons quelques bornes
d'âge pour pas pour bien comprendre que
quand on parle de vieillissement et de
vieillesse c'est une une kirielle de
situation aussi différente que celle qui
existe entre 0 et 20 ans quand on parle
de jeunesse quel est le point commun
entre un nourrisson accueilli par la PMI
et et un jeune en insertion
professionnelle accompagné par
l'émission locale c'est un peu la même
chose pour les personnes âgées le
retraité actif
euh juste après la fin sa sortie du
marché du marché du travail il a du
temps il est plutôt en bonne santé il
est sollicité par sa famille chaque
semaine les personnes âgées font autant
de garde d'enfants que l'ensemble des
services publics et privés de crèchees
ou de ou de nounous il participe à la
vie associative s'il y avait pas les
retraités ait plus une seule association
qui tournerait les conseils municipaux
bon voilà ça c'est la question de
l'utilité sociale de la place des
personnes âgées puis après allez mettons
une date 75 80 ans l'âge des fragilités
là je parle sous le couvert du médecin
la physiologie fait que bah
immanquablement on va avoir des
fragilités physiques ou psychiques lié à
l'avancée en âge et c'est là que ce nous
le cœur du du défi c'est comment on fait
pour que ces fragilités ne basculent pas
dans la pointe de la pyramide qui la
perte d'autonomie la situation de
dépendance qui pour le coup du coup
concerne une minorité de personnes âgées
et pas toutes les personnes âgées c'est
pas un cheminement linéaire et l'enjeu
je termine par là des politiques
publiques parce que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse face à ces défis c'est de
plutôt faire en sorte que grâce à la
prévention et à l'adaptation de la
société au vieillissement et bien on
accompagne les fragilités on les intègre
on les voie pour limiter les situations
de perte d'autonomie et quand elles
surviennent d'avoir des réponses qui
sont à la hauteur merci alors Hervé
Lebras j'allais dire vous êtes le mateux
le démographe le
statisticien un mot simplement sur cette
trinité y croyezvous à cette trinité
laïque bien
entendu non je je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec Jérôme gagege la peut-être
la petite nuance que j'aurais est que au
fil du temps avec le le
vieillissement les âges de séparation de
on on bougé il faut se souvenir que au
19e siècle un vieillard chez Balzac
c'est à 50 ans qu'on est un vieillard
dans le le livre que Alfred saui et le
docteur Debray avait publié les français
pour la France en 1946 chez galimar le à
partir de 60 ans on était un vieillard
ensuite on est allé jusqu'à 65 ans
maintenant vous avez dit 75 80 ans et
encore pas complètement re mais mais
c'est très important dans la mesure où
la l'état de santé a aussi suivi en
partie je trouve par exemple que les les
travaux des économistes de la santé
comme Brigitte Dormont qui montrent
quelles sont les couts de santé au lieu
de les mesurer selon l'âge les mesures
selon l'âge auquel on décède et on
s'aperçoit que tout glisse d'une
certaine manière donc c'est voudrait
être un tout petit peu plus optimiste
c'est-à-dire que quand on prend des
limit d'âge démographique vraiment je
voulais pas les prendre les limites
d'âge parce que par dire grand chose
mais ça pour éclairer un petit peu voilà
Juliette maisadelle par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une police de la
parole il faut être politiquement
correct sinon on se fait dénoncer sur
les réseaux sociaux à votre avis il faut
parler des vieux des gens âgés quel quel
est le langage approprié pour satisfaire
la doxa des réseaux sociaux je suis pas
une spécialiste de la doxa des S mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas la peine d'être
blessant alors dire les vieux c'est
quand même pas très agréable surtout que
on pense d'abord on pense à soi on se
dit qu'un jour ça ça va finir par
arriver non je crois qu'on peut dire les
personnes âgées je pense que ça me
semble assez respectueux et précisément
moi je suis frappée parce que quand
j'étais en 3e je me souviens on nous
apprenait que la démographie française
évoluait vers une pyramide des âges qui
donnait la part belle aux personnes
âgées et c'était déjà il y a une
vingtaine d'années et 20 ans plus tard
on s'aperçoit que les pouvoirs public en
tout cas au niveau présidentiel et
gouvernemental n'ont absolument pas ni
vu venir cette situation que les
démographes ont montré ni même conçu des
outils de politique publique à la
hauteur parce que Jérôme g le dit très
bien dans son rapport la question du
grand âge les personnes âgées mais c'est
comme toutes les politiques sociales en
fait ça concerne tous les domaines
l'éducation la parler vous allez voir
oui mais vous voyez bien que c'est un
problème politique massif c'est
l'éléphant dans dans l'éléphant dans
dans la pièce non mais juste un mot sur
la
politique sur la politique vous en avez
fait vous en faites euh vous pensez que
comme le sujet n'est pas clivant c'est
une des raisons pour lequell non pas du
tout je pense que quand on fait une une
politique du grand âge pour être clair
c'est pas glamour et comme les les
hommes politiques s'adressent à ceux qui
votent immédiatement donc plutôt la les
50 60 ans ils pensent d'abord à eux et
ben les 30 50 60 ans la première chose à
laquelle ils pens c'est pas tout de
suite le grand âge ça va venir mais ils
y pensent pas tout de suite et donc les
hommes politiques ils ont une vision
plutôt à courte vue donc quand on bâtit
un programme pour les présidentiels à
mon avis c'est une erreur profonde donc
on pense pas d'abord à adresser la
question du grand âge et je vais vous
dire c'est une erreur et moi je trouve
que c'est une injustice sociale profonde
on va en parler alors Monsieur Michel
vous êtes le médical si je puis dire de
l'Étap qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
qui vient d'être dit sans pour autant
vous limiter à un point de vue
thérapeutique non bien sûr al moi
j'aimerais réagir pour ce que vous avez
dit Monsieur GCH parce que pour moi le
vieillissement commence à la
conception donc en fait c'est un long
processus c'est qu'on est tous dans ce
processus avec une interaction entre
l'individuel et la société et qu'on
commence vraiment à vieillir sur le plan
individuel à partir de 45 55 ans toutes
les fonction physiologique décline à
partir de 45 55 ans et qui a un problème
majeur c'est que les personne ne se
rendent pas compte qu'elle vieillissent
et ell comprennent pas qu'ell
vieillissent et puis à un moment donné
comme ell prennent pas soin d'elle à ce
moment-là il y a un problème majeur qui
peut arriver et ce qu'a dit Monsieur
gage par rapport à ces notions de
robustesse fragilité et puis dépendance
c'est vraiment très vrai puis j'aimerais
ragir par rapport à ce que vous venez de
dire Madame moi je pense que enfin en
tout cas mon expérience c'est que les
vieux votent beaucoup plus que les
jeunes bah oui et donc en fait 75
oui mais enfin même plus enfin j'ai
l'impression que là il y a et et
vraiment moi je suis en tant que engagé
dans le domaine depuis 35 ans environ
j'avoue que je suis absolument mécontent
de ce qui se passe depuis 35 ans parce
que c'est une vague qui arrive qui est
absolument déterminée et rien n'est fait
rien n'est fait et j'arrive pas à
comprendre parce que ça sera la
prochaine pandémie et vous dites rien
n'est fait c'est-à-dire il y a quand
même des mesures sociale qui sont prises
partout dans les pays démocratiques
sentend non je pense qu'il y a pas de
conscience du vieillissement il y a pas
de conscience du vieillissement
personnel il y a pas de conscience du
vieillissement environnemental et aussi
familial et puis il y a pas de
conscience aussi du vieillissement à
l'intérieur de la maison c'est-à-dire de
là où l'on vit et et donc ces trois
consciences doivent être absolument
mises en avant pour que les personnes
qui sont vieillissante aujourd'hui se
rendent compte que elles sont en partie
les acteurs de leur propre
vieillissement très
bien oui je pense que la question de la
conscience vous avez tout à fait raison
est importante parce que en même temps
si on prend un regard sur un assez long
terme il y a eu d'énormes progrès qui
ont été fait sur le vieillissement je
vous rappelle quand le livre de Simone
de Beauvoir sur la vieillesse commence
par vieillesse et synonyme de pauvreté
actuellement le seuil de avec le seuil
de pauvreté c'est les personnes âgées
qui ont le plus faible proportion
au-dessous du seuil de pauvreté c'est
les jeunes la plus forte c'était
exactement l'inverse dans les années 80
il faut voir que en
1970 2600000 français étaient au minimum
vieillesse l'année dernière il en reste
560000 c'est 560000 de trop mais au fond
ce qui s'est produit il y a eu un énorme
progrès financier mais il y a pas eu ce
que vous dites de conscience il y a pas
eu de distinction dans les les cas les
plus graves parce que il y a des îlos de
pauvreté très importants malgré vouz
réagir vraimentement moi ce qui ce qui
me frappe vous vous rappelez Jacques
Chirac quand il voulait interpeller sur
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique alors que le phénomène est là
aussi objectivé même s'il y a eu du
cicisme un temps il disait la maison
brûle et on regarde ailleurs et bien moi
je pense que la maison vieillit et on
regarde ailleurs
euh parce que en effet on peut
considérer qu'il y a eu des progrès
médicaux des progrès du système de
protection sociale le fait qu'en effet
il y a à peine 8 % de retraités pauvres
ce qui est enessous des 14 % de
l'ensemble des Français qui est deux
fois moins que nos voisins européens et
ça c'est à mettre au crédit de notre
système de retraite donc certains disent
qu'il est trop généreux mais la réalité
que ça se traduit par un des plus
faibles taux de pauvreté on n on se
compare souvent avec les autres pays
quand on a quelque chose qui fonctionne
bien autant le autant le dire donc mais
on s'est dit la question euh retraite
égale pauvreté précarité elle est traité
mais derrière ça il y a toutes les
questions de la place des personnes
âgées dans la société c'est pour ça que
j'ai un petit désaccord avec Juliette
Méadel c'est que moi j'hésite pas à
parler de vieux parce que l'espèce de de
de de pudeur à ne pas nommer les choses
on dit bien les jeunes on dit pas les
juniors on nomme les jeunes les vieux
moi j'ai écrit un petit livre qui
s'appelle plaidoyer pour les vieux il y
a quelques années avec cette idée de
contrecarrer quelque chose qui rend
aussi compliqué tout ce qu'on appelle de
nos vœux
qui est de de lutter contre
l'invisibilisation des personnes âgées
c'est-à-dire que il y a un phénomène de
retrait de du débat public de retrait
Juliette avait raison de le rappeler
tout à l'heure dans les dernières
élections présidentielles ça n'a jamais
été un sujet de débat important comme
d'autres l'immigration la sécurité
l'éducation l'hôpital et cetera la
question du vieillissement et toutes les
conséquen sur l'ensemble de la société
était totalement écarté et cette
invisibilisation elle est à tous les
étages moins on voit les vieux moins on
se préoccupe d'eux je vous prends un
seul exemple qui est très parlant on est
sur une chaîne de télé le CSA l'ancêtre
de l'arcom il y a quelques années avait
fait une enquête en regardant sur une
dizaine d'années la présence des
personnes âgées ou des vieux dans les
journaux de 20h sur les six principales
chaînes de télévision c'était 6 % des
sujets dans les journaux de 20h quand
les personnes âgers représentent 20 % de
de la population ce que je veux dire
c'est que Sy ololiquement le fait de pas
voir que on peut parler vieillesse et
sexualité on peut parler vieillesse et
sport vieillesse et culture vieillesse
effet divers il y en a aussi
quelques-uns on le cantonner juste au
sujet soit de la retraite soit d'une
maladie soit d'une problématique
particulière ça peut paraître
anecdotique mais quand on va faire
avancer des débats de société il faut
aussi donner à voir ceux qui sont
concernés et entendre la parole des
vieux eux-mêmes pour qu'ils puissent
coconstruire cette politiqueux écoutz on
va pas rester sur ce ressenti mais juste
un mot là-dessus Juliette Méadel le on
peut on est dans cette situation parce
qu'en France c'est comme en Europe la la
la vieillesse de GO disait la vieillesse
c'est un naufrage ça ça colle à quelque
chose de négatif fait peur vous savez
c'est comme quand on veut parler des
sujets qui concernent des personnes je
me suis occupé des victimes d'attentat
de catastrophe donc des personnes qui
sont malades handicapé tout ce qui est
douloureux difficile tout ce qui évoque
de la souffrance ça ne se vend pas bien
sur les dans les dans les réseaux sur
les journaux et donc il faut changer
complètement le regard de notre société
sur la personne qui est en position de
fragilité et ça c'est un problème
politique c'est qu'il faut arrêter de ne
mettre en avant que la force la jeunesse
la beauté la richesse c'est quand même
c'est quand même le monde à l'envers la
la vraie vie n'est pas celle-là et ça
c'est une responsabilité de qui B de
celui ou de celle qui sera le futur
candidat à la présidentielle on a nousê
on a oui vous avez raison mais on a auss
si les gouvernants méritent vous avez
raison c'est aussi à la société de
porter un autre regard qu vous
réfléchissez 2 secondes tous les âges de
la vie à tous les âges de la vie on a
des moments de fragilité quand on est
petit si on est malade à l'âge adulte et
puis quand on est plus âgé qu'est-ce que
c'est cette société où on ne montre que
celui qui est fort est beau c'est aussi
pour ça que les gens votent plus c'est
qu'on a l'impression que le politique ne
protège pas le plus fragile bien écoutez
c'est une moi je trouve cette perception
un peu psychologique et fort
intéressante mais il faut qu'on rentre
aussi dans les problèmes qui se posent
alors Monsieur Michel vous qui êtes un
médecin euh parmi les sujets de
préoccupation des vieux des personnes
âgées il y a le logement alors en épad
ou maintien à domicile les deux
solutions ont leurs avantages et leurs
inconvénients comment se fait la
distribution je sais que c'est un mot
inélégant mais en vérité ça se pratique
voilà alors qu'il y a une volonté
affirmée et ça on le constate dans
toutes les statistiques les personnes
âgées veulent rester chez elles à
domicile qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
voilà alors 80 % des personnes âgées on
pourrait dire même en Europe veulent
rester à domicile et mourir à domicile
seul problème c'est que comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure vraiment elles ne
font rien pour essayer que ça se passe
bien tant sur le plan individuel tant
sur le plan du logement lui-même et puis
sur le plan environnemental familial et
autres je pense que là il y a il y a une
construction à faire qui est pas une
construction des dernières années de vie
mais qui est une construction de toute
la ville encore je reviens sur ça et et
vous n'avez pas l'air d'accord madame
oui mais on la laissera exprimer son
désaccord mais la parole est à
vous
voilà ou Mo je suis convaincu de ce que
je dis mais on va argumenter tout à
l'heure et puis je pense que les choix
ils se ils vont essentiellement dépendre
de la notion de dépendance ou de perte
d'autonomie c'estàd moi je défends je je
différencie les deux la dépendance pour
moi c'est physique et l'autonomie c'est
plus l'autonomie de décision et je pense
que les deux choses sont pas forcément
toujours associées alors la dépendance
physique vous êtes dépendant et à ce
moment-là vous pouvez un peu rester à la
maison si vous avez de l'aide la perte
de l'autonomie avec ces notions de
démence majeure sont pose d'autres
problèmes et à mon avis c'est à ce
moment-là quand il y a une rupture que
le domicile n'est plus possible et en
tant que médecin comment vous expliquez
moi en tant que journaliste j'ai il
m'arrive d'interviewer très
fréquemment certains
intellectuels qui gardent leur tête si
on peut dire même très âgé et dans des
conditions physiques désavantagées
tandis que certains dans des conditions
physiques
désavantagées ils ont aussi leur
psychisme qui vaciie comment vous
expliquez ça qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'est-ce qui fait que
le ou ça c'est un problème majeur oui
ait pris Nobel si j'arrive oui mais là
la question se pose parce que le
problème aussi c'est un problème
d'éducation on peut perdre son autonomie
physiquement mais pas psychiquement et
vice-versa c'est ça je différencie la
dépendance de l'autonomie mais euh je
pense que là c'est très compliqué à dire
je pense qu'il y a une notion
l'éducation est extrêmement importante à
la base parce que elle intervient
beaucoup dans les notions de de de perte
d'autonomie en particulier et aussi de
perte de dépendance donc là c'est ça
intervient beaucoup mais à mon avis ce
qu'il faut voir c'est immédiatement
après la personne il faut voir
l'environnement familial et
l'environnement familial il est majeur
si vous avez construit votre vie avec
autour de vous des personnes qui sont
aimantes vous arrivez mieux à rester à
domicile que si vous avez des personnes
qui vous sont qui qui il y a plus
personne autour de vous je crois que
vraiment ça c'est vraiment r gage
là-dessus sur sur le logement sur le
logement oui d'abord encore une fois il
faut il faut pas que l'arbre de la
dépendance cache la forêt du
vieillissement c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a toujours
repoussé les lois pour appréhender le
sujet parce que vous l'avez dit dans
votre propos introductif cette question
de l'accompagnement de la Perre
d'autonomie de la dépendance pour ceux
qui sont en épad dans les services à
domicile c'est une question là c'est
tout à fait planifié il faut aller
chercher de l'argent dans les 10
prochaines années 9 à 10 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et donc tous les
gouvernements ont freiné des cas de
faire en se disant ou là là on a
d'autres on a d'autres priorités
pourtant ça c'est un sujet majeur on en
reparlera peut-être mais aujourd'hui le
scandale absolu que nous vivons c'est le
mode d'organisation de nos service à
domicile voilà où on a 300 ou 400000
professionnels qui ont des conditions
travail exérable ce sont essentiellement
des femmes c'est pour ça que c'est un
sujet clivant le vieillissement parce
que derrière on y touche à des sujets
d'organisation du travail à un combat
féministe pourquoi est-ce qu'on les
services à domicile c'est la dernière
activité en France où il y a une
tarification à l'heure et parfois
quasiment à la minute dans des
situations de précarité d'interminance
d'intermittence bon ça c'est le premier
scandale le deuxième c'est dans les
épades et pas uniquement sur les mais
justement sur les pas un mot là-dessus
est-ce que ça s'est amélioré depuis ce
qu'on a appelé le scandale des épades
avec le livre de mon confrère castané
les fayurs est-ce que ça s'est amélioré
non mais ça s'est amélioré sur le point
particulier qu'il a levé c'est la
financiarisation c'estàdire la manière
dont certains groupes mais la
maltraitance c'est la maltraitance je
vais vous dire une chose un peu terrible
elle est systémique notre société ne a
décidé inconsciemment ou consciemment de
ne pas donner suffisamment de moyens
pour accompagner dignement les personnes
âgées dans les épades j'étais hier dans
un épad à Orléan et je discutais avec
des aides soignantes le matin elles sont
six aides soignantes pour s'occuper de
77 personnes ça veut dire que
concrètement elles n'ont pas le temps
pour faire la toilette pour aider à
prendre le petit-déjeuner on est encore
en France avec des des des des
situations où on va prendre une douche
tous les 15 jours donc le choix de
société qui a été fait il n'y a pas
assez de personnel dans les épades euh
alors même que les besoins sont sont
gigantesques qu'on aura toujours besoin
des épades parce qu'en effet même si les
gens privilégie le fait de rester à
domicile il y a certaines situations de
troubles cognitifs euh de dément
desambulant de polypathologie qui font
que l'épad sera nécessaire mais à
condition qu'il soit un véritable lieu
de vie et l'insuffisance de personnel
dans les épades fait que c'est à la
chaîne dans des conditions qui sont je
le redis maltraitantes on vous a entendu
là-dessus alors Hervé Le Bras est-ce
qu'il y a eu des études
démographique qui montre que des
personnes qui restent à domicile vivent
plus longtemps que si elles sont
trimballées dans des épades est-ce que
ça objectivement sans faire de démagogie
ob objectivement étant donné qu'il y a
une sélection comme vous l'avez dit de
ceux qui vont rester à domicile et les
autres c'est très difficile de faire la
séparation mais je voudrais ajouter sur
ce point-là euh quand vous avez dit à
juste titre que Ben le vieillissement se
fabrique tout au long de la vie mais il
se fabrique aussi pas simplement pour
une raison biologique c'est pour les
métiers qu'on suivi les personnes parce
que quand on regarde les dispérences
d'espéran de vie elles sont très
importantes selon la catégorie sociale
les ouvriers surtout les manœuvres ont
actuellement encore en France C an de
moins d'espérance de vie que les cadres
mais ça va beaucoup plus loin
c'està-dire quand on regarde la partie
de vie en bonne santé l'espérance de de
vie en bonne santé à ce moment-là
l'écart l'écart est encore plus grand
pour ceux qui meurent le plus jeune
c'està-dire que oui mais HERV le bras
oui nous avons eu ici sur ce plateau
plusieurs fois l'économiste Daniel Cohen
à qui je rends hommage oui bon il dit il
dit cette chose évidente que dans notsre
démocratie c'est pire ailleurs dans les
sociétés totalitaires il dit qu'il y a
constamment des avancées sociales mais
en même temps les inégalités se creusent
ce que vous êtes en train de dire mais
est-ce qu'on peut espérer un jour
inverser la tendance alors oui je pense
justement et
par on a eu des régimes de gauche on a
eu des régimes de droite et on pas V
quand on regarde à nouveau les
inégalités n'ont pas été alors les
inégalités diminué globalement si vous
voulez il y a eu une grosse diminution
des inégalités je parle pour la France
mais pour la plupart des pays développés
sauf les États-Unis jusque vers 2000 et
puis ensuite ça s'est lentement inversé
mais c'est assez lent la quand on
regarde par âge les inégalités ne sont
pas façon surprenante ne sont pas plus
importantes dans la catégorie des
personnes âgées que dans la catégorie
des personnes actives mais ça veut dire
qu'elles reste quand même importante
mais euh il y a un je dirais un
sentiment fait de la fragilité des
personnes âgées qu'elles sont plus
inégales mais es ne sont pas Juliette
merdel je voudrais qu'on on avance un
peu je vais vous donner la parole parce
que il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
posent on va pas on peut pas rester que
dans du ressenti ou du psychologique bon
il y a beaucoup de problèmes la la
transition démographique aujourd'hui
oblige à adapter la société dans son
ensemble sont concernés l'habitat on
vient d'en parler mais les transports
l'accès aux soins au loisirs à une
alimentation au numérique et cetera
comment arbitrer entre ces différentes
adaptations et lesquelles ont la
priorité parce qu'on peut pas tout faire
dans une société voilà vous avez raison
on peut pas tout faire mais quand même
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire d'abord moi
je crois qu'on doit pouvoir permettre à
quelqu'un de finir ses jours dignement
et aujourd'hui les conditions dans
lesquels on finit son existence je parle
pas des trois dernières semaines et des
soins palliatifs hein je parle vraiment
des des 10 dernières années surtout
quand on est malade le le le nombre de
maladies chroniquees de maladies
cognitives ne cesse d'augmenter il faut
quand même le dire forcément on vit de
plus en plus longtemps par ailleurs il y
a aussi un facteur environnemental sur
le développement des maladies cognitives
donc il y a une population aujourd'hui
qui est de plus en plus malade qui a de
plus en plus de mal maladie cognitive et
qui vit de plus en plus longtemps vous
savez que là l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé a diminué c'estàd qu'elle augmente
en valeur absolue mais que on sait
qu'aujourd'hui passer 65 ans on va de
plus en plus mal et on sait que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé est de
plus en plus courte c'est quand même un
signe de dégradation de nos conditions
de vie donc pour moi une priorité pour
le prochain Président de la République
serait de dire on doit finir ses jours
dignement comment on les finit dignement
moi je crois que jusqu'à ce qu'on soit
dépendant vous avez raison le maintien à
domicile comme le fait le Danemark c'est
une solution cela dit c'est une solution
très onéreuse rester chez soi avoir un
maintien à domicile tant qu'on est à peu
près capable c'est cher parce qu'il faut
quand même des aides on n pas toujours
des parents pour s'occuper de soi et
puis on a aussi des jeunes ou des jeunes
parents qui ont pas forcément envie de
le faire donc le maintien à domicile
doit être complètement réorganisé
aujourd'hui il y a un éclatement entre
département comm une c'est très
compliqué aujourd'hui d'organiser le
maintien à domicile d'une personne âgée
he il faut pratiquement un mi-temps pour
coordonné avoir les aides être présent
ouvrir la porte aux différents
intervenants donc c'est un premier sujet
le deuxième sujet c'est effectivement
les épades faut changer le modèle des
épades aujourd'hui les épades se sont
financiarisés c'est vrai mais même les
grands groupes à la tête des épades et
Orpa en tête eux sont pas assez
contrôlés c'estd qu'il faut que
maintenant qui contrôle les éepades les
ARS dans les agences régionales de santé
il y a TR qu inspecteurs envoyés vous
savez qu'il y a 23S en France TR
inspecteurs ce sont les agences
régionales de santé effectivement les
ARS sont parce qu'elles sont en
partenariat avec les départements et et
d'autres collectifal les aéren sont
chargés quand même de surveiller ce qui
se passe elles ne pilotent pas les
éepades elles sont chargé de surveiller
trois inspecteurs par ARS comment vous
voulez que l'État puisse contrôler ce
qui se passe la CNSA qui est le
financeur des pad c'est la caisse la
CNSA la caisse qui paye elle exerce pas
de P entendu mer làdessus mais donc
qu'est-ce que je dis qu'est-ce que je
dis disici l'état il faut que l'État a
une vision du grand âge et qu'il
contrôle les conditions dans lesquelles
les personnes âgées finissent leur jour
en particulier dans les épades et qui
surveillent le bien-être oui les
conditions du bien-être Monsieur Michel
vos priorité à vous
c'est tout va mal si je vous entends
par où commencer pas où commc moi moi je
suis persuadé qu'il faut commencer en
aant en prenant conscience de son propre
vieillissement et que la personne soit
responsable je suis vraiment alors
convaincu de ça autrement il y aura peut
toujours donner des solutions pour c
pour ça mais à mon avis il faut que la
personne que chacun d'entre nous on soit
conscient de ce propre vieissement et
qu'on agisse dans ce sens et vous Jérôme
g mentionne sur les mobilités le
logement et cetera il faut voir la vie
la ville et les villages avec un œil de
vieux c'estàd mettre les fragilité les
vulnérabilités euh comme porte d'entrée
de la définition des politiques
publiques à mener le vieillissement est
un phénomène territorial c'estàdire que
sociodémographes qui ont bien démontré
que pour une personne âgée ce qui est
important c'est ce qu'elle les services
et les biens auxquels elle va avoir
accès dans un rayon de 500 m autour des
chez ell c'est la raison pour moi je
suis convaincu et je parle devant une
élu municipale que les maires vont être
en première ligne
pour coordonner les enjeux du
vieillissement ils ont pas toutes les
compétences il y a les ARS il y a les
départements il y a les bailleurs
sociaux sur les logements et cetera mais
les maires ils vont devoir se poser la
question de savoir est-ce que sur mon
territoire municipal on a l'ensemble de
cette adaptation je vous prends un seul
exemple vous allez comprendre ces
dernières années dans les villes on a
retiré les bancs de l'espace public pour
des bonnes ou des mauvaises raisons
parce que les bancs les jeunes s'y
installent ils font du bruit euh parfois
il y a des sans domicile fixe et c'est
bon on peut les éloigner ce qui est pas
très ce qui est pas très sympa mais du
coup conséquence il y a moins de Ban
dans l'espace public et bien là
voyez-vous avec cette décision qui a été
prise pour une raison les jeunes les SDF
et cetera la conséquence c'est qu'on a
envoyé un message subliminal aux
personnes âgées en leur disant ne sortez
pas de chez vous parce queune personne
âgée elle a besoin quand elle va se
promener d'avoir tous les 100 ou 200 m
un endroit où elle peut se reposer et
donc on est comme dans la chanson de brê
on leur a dit du lit au salon puis du
lit au fauteuil et du lit au lit et donc
aujourd'hui concrètement je pense par
exemple à Mathieu clin le maire de Nancy
il a pris ce sujet et ça peut paraître
bizarre mais c'est un maire qui a lancé
un plan banc voilà il a posé la question
de savoir où est-ce qu'on réinstalle les
bancs comment on discute avec les
personnes âgées elles-mêmes donc ils ont
organisé ils ont organisé des
déambulation justement Jérome vous vous
êtes
députéîre comment légiférer face à cette
diversité de problèmes parce que selon
les
territoires selon les niveaux de revenus
selon les la structure familiale ça se
pose pas de la même manière je vais vous
dire d'abord c'est le cadre c'est pour
ça que moi j'aime le terme que vous avez
utilisé transition démographique parce
que les deux autres transitions qui
bouleversent nos sociétés la transition
écologique ou la transition digitale
elles sont regarder chacun s'en
préoccupe les entreprises les
collectivités locales l'État et cetera
la transition démographique la
révolution de la longévité bah pour
l'instant c'est pas le sujet prioritaire
donc la première chose c'est provoquer
le débat et donc c'est pour ça que moi
je me suis battu avec d'autres pour
qu'on ait enfin cette loi de
programmation sur le grand âge et
au-delà du seul grand âge sur la
longévité ah moi j'ai élaboré pour
stimuler le débat une une proposition
loi c'est marrant parce que le le titre
c'est pour garantir le droit à vieillir
dans la dignité et adapter la société au
vieillissement et qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans un qu'est-ce qui devrait y avoir
dans un texte comme ça parler de
compétences des communes pour leur dire
vous devez coordonner donner les acteurs
du vieillissement sur votre territoire
parler de logement euh dans le parc
social on va avoir une crise du
vieillissement majeure parce qu'on a des
cages d'escalier aujourd'hui où il y a
déjà une majorité de gens qui ont plus
de 60 ans et dans les 15 années qui
viennent parce qu'il y a pas beaucoup de
turnover dans le parc social on aura
quasiment une résidence autonomie sur
pied en fait c'est tous les sujets qui
doivent être regardés de manière
transversale et à la fin la question du
financement un débat public national qui
n'a pas encore eu lieu dans lequel on
donne la parole aux personnes âgées
ell-même parce qu'on peut pas décider
pour les personnes âgées même si et
c'est ça qui est intéressant avec le
vieillissement contrairement à d'autres
sujets c'est que nous sommes tous des
vieux en devenir c'est ça qui est
passionnant et que moi quand je milite
pour ces sujets c'est à la fois parce
que je pense que c'est un sujet
éminemment politique je vous ai dit que
c'est un sujet de de de combat féministe
mais c'est aussi un sujet d'emploi c'est
des gisements d'emploi gigantesques der
l'instant on va pouvoir les financer et
les socialiser c'est des emplois non
délocalisables non substituables vous
savez les fameux métiers du lien du soin
du CER de l'accompagnement il y a c'est
un enjeu d'aménagement du territoire il
y a des des pans entiers du territoire
national où on est d'ors déjà dans une
crise du vieillissement parce que on
parle beaucoup des déserts médicaux mais
il y a des endroits c'est des déserts
médicaux-sociaux on ne peut plus
recruter dans les épades ni dans les
services à domicile donc c'est un enjeu
pouvoir d'achat combat féministe am
aménagement du territoire emploi santé
si ça c'est pas politique et
contrairement à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure sur tous ces sujets c'est des
choix clivants à faire est-ce que c'est
plus de solidarité familiale ou plus de
solidarité nationale est-ce que c'est
des services publics ou des opérateurs
privés ça c'est ces débats là comment on
finance chacun pour soi ou bien avec moi
je propose par exemple d'augmenter les
impôts sur les successions pour financer
le le grand âge ce débat il va être
passionnant à condition qu'il ait lieu
parce qu'il va devoircher d'accord vous
serez d'accord pour qu'il y ait un grand
emprunt par exemple pour le le grand âge
je sais pas je sais pas si c'est un
emprunt qu' faut faire parce que sinon
on va là pour le coup on va alimenter
l'agisme en disant c'est à cause des
vieux et cetera non moi je suis attaché
à la logique de la sécurité sociale
d'accord
entendu je voudrais avoir votre avis
Hervé Lebras sur un point important euh
si je vous écoute le grand âge c'est une
diversité de situations
c'est d'abord sur le plan sanitaire les
niveaux de santé sont pas les mêmes sur
le plan territorial
les logements sur les il y a des gens
qui vivent jusqu'à 100 ans en très bon
état il y en a qui vent à 60 ans qui
sont déjà
dépendant démographiquement est-ce
comment on peut faire des projections
avec une à partir d'une t diversité de
situations très difficile vous avez
raison mais même la la la plus simple
projection on on parlait avec le docteur
Michel juste avant on ne sait pas très
bien comment va évoluer la l'espérance
de vie donc la mortalité au cours disons
des 10 ou 15 prochaines années il y a eu
un très fort ralentissement à partir de
du à peu près 2010 2012 pas simplement
en France en Angleterre encore plus aux
États-Unis ça change énormément de
choses en terme de qui seront quels
seront les volumes justement de de
personnes âgées donc c'est trè c'est
très difficile en plus de ça vous avez
des questions qui Politi comment les
politiques peuvent se projeter dans ce
caslà réu près la même réponse pe près
la même que pour les elle serait que
pour la question des retraites elle
serait d'abord de définir précisément
pour la retraite par exemple la question
était qu'est-ce qu'une politique juste
des retraites et ben il fallait définir
j'ai entendu dire par le gouvernement
que c'était juste les mesures mais en
quoi était-elle juste par exemple une
proposition c'est de dire et bien une
juste retraite c'est que le même nombre
de d'années travailler donne droit au
même nombre d'espéran de vie en bonne
santé à la retraite voilà voilà on peut
en discuter mais c'est l'exemple de
justice or il y a par exemple pour ce
que vous signaliez à propos de la
mobilité un un quelque chose d'assez
simple c'est de dire mais il faut qu'il
y ait une égalité de mobilité donc que
les personnes âgées puissent se déplacer
dans la ville aussi bien que les
personnes qui ne sont pasagé
autrementand dit de poser les termes en
termes clair et simples et puis un autre
point c'est juste un tout petit point à
propos du logement c'est qu'il y a on
entre dans des contradictions vous avez
parlé de vieillissement norement vous
avez tout à fait raison mais c'est aussi
parce que les personnes âgées restent
dans les logements qu'elles ont eu quand
on regarde comment évolue le nombre
moyen de personnes
par par logement en fonction du nombre
de pièces on voit que ça monte et puis
arrivé à 50 60 ans ça reste un peu près
au niveau autrement et le gros problème
de l'habitat social c'est de faire
passer les personnes qui sont dans des
logements de 3 4 C pièces dans les
studio ou des logements de deux pièces
donc il y a des tas de problèmes merci
Hervé Le Bras on va passer maintenant au
moment entrop logique si vous voulez
[Musique]
bien alors je voudrais parler avec vous
de vieillissement et d'amour à partir
d'une histoire que m'a relaté
visel l'ancien prix Nobel de la Paix un
jour il visitait un cimetière en
Amérique latine et il
était intrigué par le fait que sur les
tombes il y avait des visages très
jeunes il ne comprenait pas pourquoi
tous ces morts avaient sur leur tombe
des espèces de petits camé avec des
visages très jeunes alors il a interrogé
le gardien du cimetière en lui demandant
mais comment se fait-il que dans ce
cimetière les gens sont comme partout
ailleurs c'est des personnes âgés qui
sont décédés mais les visages ne
correspondent pas et le gardien lui a
dit vous savez dans ceci cimetière on ne
met pas la photo du défun quand il est
âgé mais on lui demande combien d'âge
d'amour il avait et par conséquent
certains avaient quelques jours d'autres
quelques années donc je voudrais vous
intéresser et vous faire parler de ce
sujet-là les vieux et les jeunes c'est
des mondes aujourd'hui qui se côtoi mais
qui se distingue les valeurs sont pas
les mêmes il y a une instantané il y a
la rapidité il y a une hyper modernité
chez les jeunes et il y a un côté
sagesse les personnes âgées et cetera
euh ils diffèrent par leur rapport à
l'intimité par leur rapport au temps et
cetera comment fait-on pour appréhender
ces générations sans les
séparer votre c'est c'est
précisément votre premier mot dans votre
introduction vous avez utilisé le terme
de guerre des âges s'il y a bien une
guerre qu'il faut qu'on évite dans ce
pays on a déjà suffisamment de lignes de
fracture voilà
euh sur les questions religieuses sur
les questions sociales et cetera et donc
nous ajoutons pas une guerre des âges
qui qui peut nous pendronner avec la
question de savoir est-ce qu'on en fait
pas trop pour les vieux euh c'est
parfois ce qui retient le législateur ou
le gouvernement de dégager des moyens en
se disant mais attendez cette génération
des BB boomers ils ont déjà eu tout ce
qu'ils voulaient ils ont profité de du
boom de l'immobilier et cetera av pas
encore en plus leur leur rajouter
d'ailleurs regardez ce qui s'est passé
pendant le pendant le covid c'était
l'inquiétude qu'on pouvait avoir on pe
avoir l'inquiétude parce qu'on a quand
même confiné pour protéger les plus
fragiles et les plus vulnérables et la
bonne
nouvelle à ce moment-là c'est qu'on n'
pas eu une sorte d'insurrection agiste
il y a eu un ou deux acteurs dans le
débat public je pense à André
conponville ou François de closé qui
avait dit c'est scandaleux de confiner
alors pour pour des vieillards qui de
toute façon devaient mourir dans les 6
ou 8 mois qui qui suivent euh donc il
faut absolument éviter cette guerre des
âges et ça ça passe par les liens
intergénérationnels parce que les
personnes âgées c'est des c'est des
vecteurs de transmission alors de
mémoire euh de sagesse de tempérance
autant de valeurs dont on a besoin dans
dans nos sociétés et ça passe
précisément par le fait d'organiser ces
liens intergénérationnel HERV le bras
sur cet aspect là hein ce rapport au
temps et même ces questions d'amour
pense qu'en fait la situation je vais
être à nouveau assez optimiste et est
très bonne en France quand on prend dans
les enquêtes on pose la question sur la
famille 96 % des Français pensent que la
famille se porte bien qu'elle est une
valeur importante c'était pas du tout la
même chose dans les années 30 c'était le
famille je vous aie c'était quitter la
famille une chambre en ville donc il y a
il y a eu au fond je dirais même c'est
un des problèmes pas simplement en
France il y a eu un certain sur la
famille c'est le slogan qui est euh
malheur public bonheur privé vous l'avez
entendu notamment à cause d'une certaine
déception vis-à-vis de la politique par
exemple et il y a donc il y a là-dedans
plutôt un un au fond un thème d'espoir
ça n'empêche pas que il y a des
personnes la plus grande injustice d'une
certaine manière c'est qu'il y a des
personnes qui ont beaucoup de familles
et des personnes qui ont très peu de
familles au fond l'État a été créé pour
égaliser ces situations individuelle
très diffelle euh je reviens sur ma
question initiale à la fois sur la
citation de Philippe taoreton et sur
l'histoire
d'ellisel quel rapport on peut faire
entre les personnes âgées et la cet
amour qui est associé à cette génération
comme porteuse d'amour pour les jeunes
générations vous savez moi je suis pas
très friantee de généralité par parce
que je crois que ce qui détermine la
relation entre un petit enfant et son
grand-père ou sa grand-mère c'est le
transgénérationnel c'estàdire c'est ce
que le grand-père ou la grand-mère a
transmis à l'enfant puis ensuite au
petit-enfant et je crois que les liens
de famille sont irréductiblement lié à
l'intime à l'individu à son histoire à
sa spécificité je crois que le politique
a pas grand-chose à faire là-dedans en
revanche là où politique peut faire des
choses c'est sur l'éducation apprendre
qu'on doit prendre soin du plus
vulnérable quel est le plus qui est le
plus vulnérable bah dans la sphère
familiale c'est le malade l'handicapé la
personne âgée mais c'est d'abord sur le
terrain de la question de la
solidarité nationale familiale que peut
se porter le discours du politique
l'amour dont vous parliez ça ne
s'apprend pas dans des lois l'amour
c'est quelque chose qui se transmet qui
est qui est li à vous ce que vous êtes
mais la solidarité c'est une
obligation civique si je puis dire et
ça oui monsieur Michel là-dessus parce
que moi je je je suis entièrement
d'accord avec ce que vous venez de dire
la la chose qui est peut-être qu'il faut
qu'on réapprenne c'est à vivre tous
ensemble voilà et et et ça on l'a plus
actuellement et c'est ce qu'il faut il
faut penser aux sociétés dans d'autres
continents qui ont encore le la personne
âgée comme la personne importante de la
famille alors que chez nous c'est pas
tout à fait le cas oui mais vous dites
qu'il faut apprendre il faut dire vous
dites qu'il faut apprendre à vivre
ensemble oui or ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est exactement le
contraire oui vous avez un clivage selon
les âges vous avez un clivage selon les
sexes vous avez un clivage selon les
genes vous avez un clivage selon les
options politiques vous avez un clivage
selon les fantasmes selon les mythes et
cetera bon comment dans ce cadre-là et
et en même temps avec une une
distribution des valeurs qui sont
distinctes alors comment faire dans ce
cadrel oui mais ce que vient de dire
madame madelle est vraiment important
parce que au sein de la famille la
personne âgée elle est encore intégrée
et elle fait partie de la famille donc
il y a peut-être des distinctions comme
vous venez de le citer au niveau global
et général mais au sein de chaque
famille il y a ce respect en en en dans
dans l'ensemble et cette notion
d'intergénérationalité est vraiment
importante et à mon
alors je vais mettre en cause une
politique avec Jérôme Gedge là-dessus
les barrières
d'âge politiqu sont portte une
responsabilité les syndicats aussi euh
je vais vous dire vous prenez certaines
profession très capé intellectuellement
scientifiquement à 65 ans quand elles
partent à la retraite elles sont
toujours très capées et très capable et
elle pourrait faire du tutorat et cetera
or les barrières d'âge aujourd'hui on
n'arrive pas à les franchir ah ben je
vais être très clair dans le prongement
de ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure en
dénonçant l'agisme potentiel euh
l'agisme c'està-dire cette
discrimination liée à l'âge qui peut
être de droit ou de fait il faut la
combattre avant qu'elle débouche sur une
guerre des âges et les barrières d'âge
c'est la l'incarnation la plus palpable
de de cette forme de séparation dès
qu'on entend le mot barrière d'âge il
faut faire gaffe c'est dire que passer
un certain âge vous avez des droits qui
reculent et donc moi ça peut paraître
contreintuitif pour un homme de gauche
euh mais je suis totalement hostile à
l'existence de barrière d'âge si
quelqu'un veut continuer à pouvoir
travailler au-delà d'un certain âge il y
a des limites dans le droit de la
fonction publique mais aussi dans le
droit privé puisque à partir de 70 ans
votre employeur peut légalement vous
licencier au nom de votre de votre âge
ça n'existe pas dans les professions
libérales on a des médecins des avocats
des notaires des huissiers qui peuvent
continuer aussi longtemps qu'ils veulent
donc un on supprime les barrières
arrière d'âge dans le rapport au travail
mais on mais on n introduit pas dans de
nouveaux dispositifs je vous prends un
exemple vous allez comprendre ce que
peut être l'agisme à chaque fois qu'il y
a une personne âgée un octogéèire qui
prend à contresens la bretelle
d'autoroute et qui provoque un drame sur
la route avec un accident on a le débat
immanquable dans les émissions de radio
ou dans les journaux en disant est-ce
qu'il faut retirer le permis de conduire
ou faire repasser le permis de conduire
passer à passer un certain âge voilà ça
c'est de la qu'on pose la question pour
nous tous parce que on peut avoir des
problèmes de santé à 50 60 70 ans la
question de savoir si on doit pas avoir
régulièrement parce qu'on a passé son
permis à 18 ans et que 50 ans après ou
60 ans après ce serait pas incongru pour
nous tous et nous toutes d'avoir une
petite évaluation donc le droit commun
mais pas de
stigmatisation liée à l'âge parce que
ben ça participe de ce que j'aiévoqué
tout à l'heure la relégation
l'invisibilisation des des personnes
àgées est vrai pardon pour le rapport à
l' print aujourd'hui passer un certain
âge mais pas pas pas âgé hein au-delà de
je crois 60 ou 65 ah bah les conditions
des banques ou d' quand vous voulez
emprunter de l'argent pour acheter une
voiture que vous avez plus de 60 ou 65
ans B plus personne ne vous prête
d'argent donc c'est quasiment une espèce
d'atteinte à votre autonomie à votre
dignité alors que vous pouvez être en
parfaite santé donc vous avez payé des
impôts toute votre vie travaillez toute
votre vie vous êtes en bonne santé et le
système financier bancaire qui ne prend
jamais de risque en réalité prennent
jamais risque ces gens-là vous déni le
droit de vous endetter politiquement
vous êtes aussi pour politiquement on
devra interdire ça pour oui on est bien
d'accord mais pour franchir les
barrières d'âge c'est-à-dire permettre
des tutoras des mais je je crois que les
barrières d'âge de doivent pas exister
dans le temps François Hollande avait
inventé en 2012 le contrat de génération
donc on avait on avait travaillé sur
cette idée qu'il pouvait y avoir une
personne dans une entreprise un senior
qui pouvait accompagner un jeune bon ça
a jamais bien fonctionné mais il faut
faut travailler cette idée cette idée de
solidarité transgénérationnelle et puis
de toute façon aujourd'hui vous avez
plein de personnes à la retraite en
pleine forme qui se mettent dans du
bénévolat parce que d'abord ça les
maintient qui transmettent je suis pour
qu'on les encourage qu'on les valorise
et puis qu'on les rige aussi comme un
modèle de d'être d'être à dans la
société d'être actif des pays mettons
aux États-Unis si vous prenez les
universités il y a pas de limite d'âge
pour un universitaire aux États-Unis et
en même temps on s'aperçoit qu' ils
partent à un âge
relativement relativement jeune entre 65
et 70 ans pour cette émission en tout
cas pour cette émission on n'a pas fait
de ségrégation d'âge alors je
voudrais écoutez l'auteur de ces mots
s'y implique également mais on va
terminer puisqu'il nous reste très peu
de temps et pour donner un peu d'espoir
et cetera dans la vie des personnes
âgées au-delà des améliorations
socio-économique dont on a parlé pendant
cette
heure il y a des choses qui sont sont
moins utilitaires peut-être plus
ludiques qui font retour à ce qu'un
philosophe appelait un presque rien que
vous avez quelque chose qui qui donne de
la vie à la vie à votre avis quelle
aération vous donneriez
pour changer la vie en quelque sorte
vous demande pas de créer de nouveaux
impôts et cetera on en a parlé mais là
on est dans les non moi je suis
euh je suis vraiment médecin et et je
vois la la parcours de vie j'arrive pas
à me concentrer sur le grand je vois ça
en parcours de vie et dans ce parcours
de vie la chose qui est la plus
importante et qui est la nouvelle
définition du vieillir en bonne santé
c'est être fonctionnellement actif
jusqu'au bout pour avoir un bien-être au
grand âge et pour moi la notion de
maladie n'existe plus elle est surpassée
par la notion de fonctionnalité tout au
long de la vie bien Juliette madel
là-dessus je voudrais associer est
l'idée d'âge à l'idée de plénitude c'est
pas parce qu'on est vieux qu'on est
malheureux on peut très bien être bien
portant ou mal portant mais heureux
c'est-à-dire apaisé jusque dans les
derniers moments de sa vie c'est une
question de de psychologie
d'accompagnement de valeur et tout ça se
travaille dans nos dans nos discours
politiques et de société oui Jérôme gate
làdus la vieillesse n'est pas une
maladie voilà il faut marteler cela
accompagne la vieillesse est une chance
et le vieillissement de la population
c'est une chance pour notre pays ça va
pas être vécu comme un un boulet comme
quelque chose d'anxiogène simplement
c'est un défi auquel là je me mets sous
l'angle de la décision de la puissance
publique auquel nous devons nous adapter
que nous devons anticiper et inciter je
suis d'accord avec vous chacun à avoir
la lucidité de regarder son propre
vieillissement pour le préparer dans de
bonnes conditions c'est ça le libre
arbitre làdus en de mots on un petit peu
en rebour ne pas croire que les
personnes âgées étaient bien traité dans
l'ancien temps c'était horrible un grand
nombre de travaux de anthropologie
historique sur le 18e siècle montre
comment maison dans la Lozère on les
plaquait contre une porte jusqu'à ce
qu'elles étouffent comment elles étaient
chassées du logis en pucardti il y a
énormément d'études sur ce sujet donc
j'aimerais bien mon souhait c'est de
dire reconnaissons qu'on a quand même
fait des progrès même s'il en reste
beaucoup à faire merci merci de cette
note d'optimisme alors il me reste à
vous présenter une brève bibliographie
alors Jérôme G vous avez publié rapport
sur rapport
concernant les personnes âgées mais vous
avez également publier un pladoyer pour
les vieux euh cette question ça a
stimulé chez vous un côté littéraire qui
vous a poussé à écrire euh on a pas
beaucoup de temps je sais que la
question est importante mais en tous les
cas de participer à l'alimentation du
débat du débat public euh et y compris
dans la culture populaire c'est assez
intéressant dans le roman dans le le
cinéma dans les séries on voit de plus
en plus et c'est tant mieux des des des
personnes âgées et c'est aussi une
manière de participer de cette de cette
reconnaissance et de de cette pleine
participation à la vie de la cité voilà
alors Hervé Lebras vous avez publié un
atlas des inégalités che autrement
flamarion les éditeurs et donc c'était
pour montrer cette persistance mais en
même temps vous dites que ça s'améliore
pour les personnes âgées oui enf terme
mais c'est surtout dans cet atlas on
voit aussi on en a peu parlé qu'il y a
de très fortes différences géographiques
en France c'est le but d'un d'un Atlass
et on pourrait aussi parler qu'il y a au
fond une montée d'une ségrégation des
des âges qui est un autre problème à la
à la fois dans les villes mais aussi
entre régions alors je voudrais signaler
l'ouvrage de Philippe toreton mémé chez
l'iconoclas dont on a eu un film qui est
passé je crois que c'était sur France 2
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez un livre
à suggérer je vous recommande un rapport
oui de la Cour des comptes qui apporte
qui porte sur les soins palliatifs sur
les soins palliatif soins palliatifs je
vous le recommande il a été remis à
l'Assemblée nationale nous l'avons remis
et qui insiste sur la question de
l'accompagnement psychologique des
derniers jours et dont le maître mot
c'est permettre de mourir le plus
sereinement possible à bon entendeur et
Monsieur mich moi j'étais responsable
d'un groupe européen pour la tout les
Fédération européenne des académies de
médecine qui a été publiée en 2019 et
qui s'appelle transformer le futur du
vieillissement et qui est
essentiellement ciblé sur ce que j'ai
dit le fonctionnement en bonne le
vieillissement en bon fonctionnement
voilà ben vous voyez pour nos
téléspectateurs voilà de bonnes lecture
il me reste à vous remercier Madame
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à notre équipe de
LCP qui a permis sa réalisation et avant
de vous laisser je vous soumets cette
site
vieillir est encore le seul moyen qu'on
a trouvé de vivre longtemps bon c'est de
sain
[Musique]
B